now friends and family described the
eleven people killed in the shooting as
loving caring and pillars of this
community they were at this temple
nearly every day in every week eight men
and three women were killed the youngest
was fifty-four the oldest was 97 they
include a married couple two brothers
and a doctor all beloved by their
synagogue and their neighborhood
Niki batiste looked at the lives that
they led she's nearly outside the tree
of life she's here with me right now
actually and so many incredible stories
you hear about these people whose lives
were taken they were unbelievable people
many of this many of the victims lived
in this Jewish community their entire
lives one couple even got married at the
Tree of Life synagogue here 62 years ago
the 11 victims each have different
stories and different backgrounds but
their shared impact here will not be
forgotten he would give the shirt off
your back he would help anybody that
needed help Steven Holl says faith was
everything to his uncle Daniel Stein and
when Hall received an alert of an active
shooter at the Tree of Life synagogue
Saturday morning he feared the worst
right away my heart sank I called my
aunt right away and she picked up the
phone and was yelling Steven I can't get
a hold of him I said let me try and we
tried to call and I got nothing but a
voicemail dr. Jerry Rabinowitz was a
highly respected doctor in the area his
friend and colleague dr. Tracy Levy
described him as loving what was he like
very kind and caring and concerning
and just a real human being and we
wouldn't use the word mensch
Joyce Feinberg was a research specialist
at the University of Pittsburgh's
learning research and development center
the staff there called her an engaging
elegant and warm person 65 year-old
Dennis Richard Gottfried had just
celebrated his 38th wedding anniversary
and a tweet his nephew Jacob said today
I lost an important person in my life my
uncle was murdered doing what he loved
praying to God and brothers Cecil and
David Rosenthal who both were special
needs adults were mainstays at the Tree
of Life synagogue attending services
weekly I knew Cecil were family friends
rabbi Morty root if called Cecil sweet
and kind people of all abilities are
very much a part of the community it's
all kind of part of that fabric of what
the community is know Cecil was as well
funerals in the Jewish religion are
usually soon after someone passes away
but the coroner's office will have to
balance its investigative findings with
the burials in Viana the first funeral
is scheduled for tomorrow for the
Rosenthal brothers and one resident here
told me Cecil Rosenthal was like the
honorary mayor of this town these two
brothers everyone loves these two
brothers and I think the the Yiddish
word mensch is something that we're all
going to be using here as we talk about
these people whose lives were taken and
of course Thank You Nikki we'll have
much more ahead from Pittsburgh
including a conversation by CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor with a rabbi and
three of the faithful who worship at the
Tree of Life synagogue why they say
working together is the best way to
respond to trauma and before I toss it
back to you nor I just wanted to let you
know that it's been reported that a
children's Shabbat service was scheduled
as it typically is on Saturdays for that
morning one of the children was not able
to make it and they rescheduled it for
Sunday there could have been a lot more
casualties including children in this
terrible shooting
oh I'm not as so chilling to hear that
and you think about so many of the
victims who were really dedicated not
only to their religious community but
also to the pittsburgh community helping
people in need they spent their lives as
good good people I still I still can't
get over this story and I keep thinking
how many more times does this have to
happen the fact that you go to a place
of worship and you were vulnerable in a
place of worship I still can't
understand it and they were there as the
USA Today writes in their lead they were
there to celebrate life that was the
purpose of their guys call the tree of
life yeah it's heartbreaking we have a
discussion too about how people get
radicalized online through some social
media sites how this could happen and
we're going to continue that
conversation throughout this show